what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
players stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion a nice
suit are you Marcello's no tax attorney
I am speaking at charity event tonight
you're wearing this okay hold on I need
to make a coffee so today we're going to
be helping one of the greatest
playmakers in the game look a mortgage
positive Luca Luca is one of the most
entertaining creative footballers on the
pitch but off the pitch he could use a
little bit of help and that's where we
come Hey look what's good my man oh I
understand you have to give a big hug at
the charity dinner tonight charity
events are great opportunity to build
your brand and to get great press Lucas
got to take advantage of that and we're
here to show him how
what is your shirt checkers we'll just
offended all of Croatia weather please
take that off
Lukas Tyler dress should reflect his
style of play sharp create unpredictable
I don't know about this I know you need
an exit come here
okay show me your celebration just after
a goal is the best time take the focus
away from your team and on to you but
without the signature celebration is
like wave it's cool
now that Lukas guys on the field
celebration down I need to show him how
to celebrate off the field
[Applause]
Joe man who are these Bobo's that's my
wife and my kids Lucas a family man and
I respect that I just want to expand his
family to include a few influencer
models and maybe an American rapper Luka
I want you to meet Tiger so fair oh I
don't know this weird ass on Wilson
looking do this but they're family ten
grand a day so four so Lucas got great
hair but she can do so much more sit
[Music]
now that's a galactic well you may not
be a striker but you look striking I'm
going to Chile tonight so remember if I
can go from refuge it'll galactic Oh
so can you tada
so do you guys have any questions yes
you know he's dying up there what is
this they still don't care about him I
think we need to bring in the big guns
stop the sweaty piece of me Mario papa
Balotelli
everyone I get a power
[Music]